-White House Press Secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
has been holding a lot
of press briefings lately,
but I don't think --
I personally don't think
all the questions we need
answered have been asked.
So we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right --
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the Late Night Press Corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night"
White House Press Briefing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Sarah, yes, Sarah, over here!
Sarah! Sarah! Sarah, over here.
Yes, thank you, Seth Meyers,
"Late Night With Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders, I have
a couple of questions
I'd like to ask if you
if you don't mind.
Why have Donald and Melania
looked so unhappy
since the election?
-They didn't want to win.
[ Laughter ]
-When was the last time
President Trump saw his feet?
-The days of Ronald Reagan.
[ Laughter ]
-Where's Sean Spicer working
nowadays?
-At the local Walmart.
-What's your favorite part
of this job?
-Purposely misleading
the American people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very well. Write that down.
-What do Eric and Donald Jr.
do at the White House?
-Repeatedly beg for money.
[ Laughter ]
-What would be
a horrible premise
for a "Thelma & Louise" sequel?
-First Lady Melania Trump
and Second Lady Karen Pence
will travel to Texas.
-Ugh.
[ Laughter ]
It's been reported
that the President
eats a lot of McDonald's.
if true, he must leave behind
a pretty devastating fart cloud.
-I've walked through
that a couple of times now.
[ Laughter ]
-My sympathies.
What's the most bonkers thing
you've ever heard
Betsy DeVos say?
-Tuesday was created in 2012.
[ Laughter ]
-What does Melania call
the first time
she went out with Donald?
-The day which will live
in infamy.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, what's going on with
Eric's birthday party?
-As of right now,
that's not something
that's currently being planned
and not something that
I'm aware is moving forward
in any capacity.
[ Laughter ]
-What's Donald Trump's favorite
part about being president?
-The corruption.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know he lost
his election in Alabama,
but what are Judge Roy Moore's
preferences
when it comes to dating?
-15's better than 20,
20's better than 22.
[ Audience groans ]
-What were the results
of Trump's brain scan?
-There's no gray area there.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it true --
is it true that Trump
took a meeting
with the heiress to the La-Z-Boy
recliner fortune?
-I'm not aware if the President
spoke specifically
with the chair woman.
[ Laughter ]
-Chair woman, you know?
[ Applause ]
[ Scoffs ]
-Is it true that Eric
spray-painted a penis
on the hood of
Robert Mueller's car?
-That's exactly what he did.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you describe it?
-That was pretty lengthy
and pretty detailed.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, let's do the jingle
for Almond Joy and Mounds
candy bars together.
-Sometimes...
-♪ You feel like a nut ♪
-And a lot of times you don't.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
That was a lot of fun.
[ Laughter ]
-What does Eric run into when
he's walking down the street?
-Pole after pole after pole.
[ Laughter ]
-How often does President Trump
exercise?
-10 separate times
over the last 20 years.
-Does the President
believe in Satan?
-The President
not only knows him,
but has played golf with him.
[ Audience groans ]
-Well, looks like
we're out of time,
so behalf on the rest
of the press corps,
have a good night. We'll be
right back with James Franco.
[ Cheers and applause ]